y si tiene apenas siete años y ya camina
sola en búsqueda de un mejor futuro su
padre la envió para que intentara cruzar
la frontera con eeuu tras haber viajado
durante 22 días junto a ella habían
intentado pero lo de olvidar
y color y ahorita sólo deja la cola para
que la niña sola sin tragar su
progenitor desistió y regreso a honduras
y ahora y se avanza junto a otros
migrantes que la cogieron en el camino
los niños que llegan solos tienen más
oportunidades de quedarse y ahora isis
podría convertirse en una más miles de
menores llegan sin familia eeuu sólo en
febrero llegaron cerca de 9.500 la
oposición republicana ha acusado al
gobierno de joe biden de crear una
crisis humanitaria en la frontera el
propio gobierno se encargó de dar a
conocer las imágenes de los centros de
refugio de texas donde preocupan las
condiciones de hacinamiento y la falta
de distanciamiento en plena pandemia de
kobe 19 en ese contexto representantes
de los gobiernos de estados unidos y
méjico emprendieron diálogos en un
intento de abordar y mitigar las causas
de la migración con miras a lograr un
flujo ordenado si perseveramos y
actuamos de conjunto
desde dijimos podemos lograr que en
estos países y el sur de méxico tener
otro futuro
tenemos dos posibilidades que me tengan
que emigrar por pobreza por inseguridad
por desesperanza sino que lo que no
quiere hacer por opción la
administración mexicana anunció que los
diálogos continuarán informa también que
por el momento no se ha llegado a ningún
acuerdo definitivo